اتصلت امرأة في لوس أنجلوس بالشرطة طلبًا
للمساعدة بعد أن قالت إن الرجل لن
يتركها بمفردها وأنه لن يترك
شقتها، وكان هذا عنفًا منزليًا،
واسمها ناني فينلون،
وكان اسمها ناني فين لون، وانتهى بها الأمر
بالقتل على يدها.  أحد نواب الشريف
الذين استجابوا بشكل جيد الآن ترفع عائلتها دعوى قضائية
للحصول على 70 مليون دولار وتطالب
بالمساءلة، الدعوى موجهة ضد
مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس ومكتب الشريف، وقد
أصدروا صوتًا لمكالمة fin L's 911،
وإليك بعضًا منها من هو اسمه
وحده  سؤال سيدتي، سيدتي
سؤالي هو من هو بالنسبة
لك، سؤالي هو من هو بالنسبة
لك،
مرحباً، مرحباً، اللعنة، نعم، أحتاج إلى
الشرطة هنا الآن، لأنه لن
يرفع يديه عني و  لقد
أخبرته بالفعل ألف مرة اخرج يا سيدتي،
ابتعد حتى أتمكن من التحدث معك
جيدًا، يقول النواب عندما وصلوا،
كانت فين إل تحمل سكين المطبخ،
سمعوها تهدد الرجل الذي كان
صديقها السابق ثم أطلقوا عليها
النار.  كانت تمسك الرجل بيد واحدة
والسكين باليد الأخرى ينضم إلينا
الآن والد ناني، لامونت فين إل ومحامي
العائلة برادلي غيج، شكرًا
لكما على وجودكما معي، لدينا
أه زاويتان من فيديو كاميرا الجسم هنا
أه السيد فينل أنا  سأحذرك أولاً من
أننا سنسمع اللقطات على الرغم من أننا
لن نراها ويمكنك رؤية
nean finl على الجانب الأيسر من
شاشتك، لذا دعنا نلعب ذلك ثم
نتحدث، اخرج، اخرج، نعم،
سأذهب  إلى St هنا لأنه P
my hey، hey، hey، he
me، he
me، على بعد ثوانٍ من الدخول إلى
تلك الشقة، السيد fin L عندما رأيت
ذلك، ما رأيك، ما الذي
شعرت به عندما رأيت تلك اللقطات من كاميرا الجسم
جيدًا، كما تعلم  إنه مثل
ما قلته في ثوانٍ، كما لو أنه
فعل ذلك في ثانية واحدة،
مروع، كابوس، كارثة كاملة،
حطام قطار، ترى السيدة الشريف
تسلمه مسدسًا صاعقًا، فيرمي المسدس
أرضًا ويبدأ تلقائيًا في إطلاق النار من
سلاحه، هذا هو الأسوأ
الشعور في العالم خلال العطلات
بفقدان طفلك من شرطي ليس لديه
تدريب ولديه تاريخ في قتل
العدالة، لذلك
لا توجد كلمات أريد أن أذكرها
وأظهر تلك اللحظة لأنها لدينا
حيث  الضابط الذي أطلق
الطلقات القاتلة يطلب من الضابط الآخر،
الضابطة، الحصول على مسدس الصعق، لذا دعونا
نعزل هذا الجزء ونشاهده
وهو يصدر
[تصفيق]
مسدس الصعق ويمكننا أن نرى من زاوية أخرى
حيث يتخلص من ذلك
على الفور تقريبًا أريد أن أقرأ  بالنسبة لك أه،
يحسب مكتب شريف لوس أنجلوس سياسة استخدام القوة مع
الأخذ في الاعتبار ما شاهدناه للتو،
يحق لأعضاء القسم
استخدام القوة المميتة على
شخص آخر فقط عندما يعتقدون بشكل معقول
أه بناءً على مجمل
الظروف أن هذه القوة
ضرورية لأي منهما  سببين والسبب
الأول هو الدفاع ضد
تهديد وشيك بالقتل أو
إصابة جسدية خطيرة للعضو أو
لشخص آخر فتجيب ناني على الباب
وفي يدها سكين وتقول سأطعنه
أه ضابط يقول تعال هذا  بدلاً من ذلك،
تسير في
الاتجاه المعاكس نحو الرجل الجالس على الأريكة الذي
يمسكه بيد واحدة والسكين باليد
الأخرى المحامي غيج، أليس من
المعقول الاعتقاد بأنها ستستخدم
تلك السكين بعد ذلك لتفعل ما قالت إنها ستطعنه
لم يكن اعتقادًا معقولًا أن تفعل
ذلك، أولاً وقبل كل شيء، كانوا يعلمون أن
نيان كانت على الهاتف لأكثر من 16 دقيقة مع
صراخ 911 وهي تحمل سكينًا خلال هذا
الإطار الزمني إذا كانت ستستخدمه
وتتسبب في إصابة خطيرة لكانت قد
فعلت ذلك.  قبل دقائق من
وصول هؤلاء النواب، هذا أول شيء
وثانيًا، كانت الأوامر الصادرة عن
النواب بعيدة كل البعد عن الوضوح، فهم يستمرون في
قول مرحبًا مرحبًا، هذا ليس صحيحًا
ولا يتوافق مع السياسة، ما كان
ينبغي عليهم فعله هو ما يقال ولكن في
الليل نخرج.  هنا
سنهتم بالكلمات التي
تؤثر على الموقف ثالثًا، كان بإمكانهم استخدام
قوة أقل فتكًا بما في ذلك مسدس الصعق أو
رذاذ الفلفل لكنهم ألقوا بها بعيدًا بدلاً من ذلك، لذا
انتهى بهم الأمر باستخدام القوة المميتة عندما
لم يكن ذلك ضروريًا